150 maybe to 250 000 a year it would be
comfortable for sure the more the
merrier but that'd be comfortable I was
just having this conversation with my
friend and she was like
you have to manifest a husband girl like
you have to really think about the
lifestyle that you want to live when it
comes down to vacations and how many
kids you want to have and
um
just like the lifestyle that you want to
have and I feel like
I don't know what it is but anytime I
hear a man my own woman say the word
manifest
I already know they're going to be
goofiest like it gives me the vibe like
you grow up on Harry Potter and you
believe in magic so let's find out
ideally my husband needs to be making
like it's to be making like okay my
suspicious she's gonna say a 175
250. 250 like 650 000.
I was being
I was being generous
whoa
okay 650k
man keep manifesting
okay
650. I have to believe they didn't grow
up poor I have to Blink them I just
can't imagine growing up poor
being around other poor people yeah
seeing constant poverty your whole life
casually
yep
you just sat there skedaddle talked
about an ideal income and you said over
half a milli she said 650. there's no
way
listen I make good money now and I'm
gonna be honest with you until I started
making good money I couldn't even
conceptualize good money
because all I'd seen my whole life is
middle class or poverty that it's all
I've ever known
that's all I've ever done there is no
way you come from a poor background bro
and you talk like that bro unless I'm
unaware and folks are so plugged into
Instagram
that they've now left their [ __ ]
Stratosphere and are dreaming in a
different one maybe I'm unaware maybe
we'll learn more hope they go into what
their background was you know what it
reminds me of it reminds me of the uh
the the woman named Charlotte the one
who works at Starbucks and then one day
decides hey you know what would be a
great idea with my zero qualifications
eh I'm going to go to Africa and build
this school it is like that
that is what it makes me think of yeah a
delusion a sickness of the highest order
has come here she said she wants a money
as if she takes a poo poo right and then
money is coming out and the other one is
eating it's like ice cream
and they are sucking up their money at
the anus thinking of your future what
percent of the family income do you
personally want to contribute so I
really want to be a stay-at-home mom so
like so I guess I wouldn't be
contributing financially I don't want
any of my income to be needed in the
family I I want the man to be 100
the supporter but that doesn't mean that
I'm not going to work and I'm not going
to have my own business then we [ __ ]
we [ __ ]
if I bring a hundred percent you need to
bring a hundred percent of something
else
just stay in the whole mom what's this
we [ __ ]
I haven't had [ __ ] when I'm bringing
the [ __ ] and the money home I bring
it home headache no headache
I bring my Hundred you bring your
hundred you're gonna stay there and not
do nothing you're gonna be a
stay-at-home mom and we [ __ ]
four weeks you think stay home moms
don't [ __ ] hold on I'm just I'm just
putting it out there that there's no say
there's no saying I don't wanna you're
gonna have something okay so what you're
trying to get at is like if I have to
hold my end of the bargain you gotta
hold yours listen
people really don't think like a
relationship is not that do you think
it's a duty they have a duty to [ __ ]
their husbands yup I said that I said
that
when you go in a relationship with
someone there's some things that are
expected when you go in a relationship
with someone
parameters of your relationship there's
some things that are expected if you
expect
the dude to bring a hundred percent of
the money there's don't even try to go
out there thinking that there's not some
things that are going to be expected out
of you yes it is a duty it is a duty
okay yeah I said that expectation
absolutely okay no I don't have to do it
you know
if expected
it's expected you imagine it's like yo
where's the money at I don't have to do
it
baby we're gonna be homeless tomorrow's
like I I have a headache today I have a
headache today things are expect I'm
sorry even even your girl got a headache
you still gonna try to bang her leave
her alone bro yeah her head hurts yeah
she's sick yeah so guess what you bring
95 of that I'll bring 95 of that dude
come on bro
absolutely there's gonna be something if
you make it that late even in a
relationship when it's easy to read bro
even in a relationship when it's 50 50
and with the bills because we're in a
relationship you bring 100 100 I know I
know you you trolling his foot but in a
relationship where you're 50 50 right
that you're supposed to there's some
things that are going to be expected you
know I mean my girl expect me to throw
the trash out
if I don't do it she's gonna be like
I threw the trash out but that was
expected on me to do it but if you got a
headache and you're sick I gotta do it
you got a fever and you're in bed I
don't wanna I don't want my place to
stink up stink up no my garbage needs to
get out but okay let's say you had a
fever One's Gonna slide but after that
you're in bed you're bedridden yeah
that's when you get a day off I could
get a day off okay but I gotta make it
up to some it's expect there's some
things that are expected and if you do
not want to uh
um acknowledge that that's delusion
right there okay all right that's fair
she's good
I'm not I'm just saying I just said we
[ __ ] breed and stop for real show me
what you got if I'm painting a picture
if it's my ideal life I would love to
just be a stay-at-home wife with some
hobbies and you know raising a family
because that's just the way I grew up
you know I had a stay-at-home mom and it
was just a really good environment to
have now I want to talk about your ideal
lifestyle so thinking
how many bedrooms how many square feet
what are we thinking
um I mean I don't need anything you know
crazy spacious but I definitely do want
a big enough home where everybody can
have their own you know individual
selves and space to feel comfortable so
just depending on lifestyle and family
at least three to four bedrooms for sure
two full baths okay and what about a car
I know you like bars yeah if it if it
could be anything
you know if it's my dream it'd probably
be
a Pagani BC which is like a hypercar but
what
do you even know what a Pagani is look
up Pagani
Pagani like this yes my man oh y'all
seen this how much does it doesn't
Batman drive one of these 2.6 billion
thank you that is my face
is that 2.6 uh
for akara
and you want a family and you want to be
a fair home in her in her defense she
said dream
yes yes 2.6 million in a dream world I
imagine the dream world I got a floating
Castle what's wrong with that I don't
have a floating Castle it's my dream but
yeah you know what I'm I'm not shaved
her because you know how much would a
[ __ ] Castle what a little bit less
than 2.6 million
she said a hypercar
when she said Pagani I lost that [ __ ]
probably at least
like 1.5 mil for sure at least okay so
what about what about not the dream car
but something more realistic maybe like
some sort of like F12 Ferrari like an
a12 super fast would be super yeah don't
do this to Mecca I try lady I really try
to save you I I know you're not gonna do
it but I'll do it how much oh 379. okay
that's not too bad actually three
three when you don't work it's true it's
true it's true how much are those like
80 no those are probably uh depending
like 300 000 to 525k what would you want
his income to be if you're gonna be a
stay-at-home mom like what kind of range
would his income be
um
I feel like this is going to sound bad I
feel like like 300 000 like I guess if
they made less than that I feel like we
wouldn't have the lifestyle I wanted so
I would work right
anywhere from 70 to 100K I would have to
say 127.
five hundred thousand dollars
is that bad
okay
okay my girl
this is the only way you bring this back
for me I hope courty ass is someone like
oh like these girls got like me from
millionaire families
for them to be saying I want a husband
with 500 you understand how small that's
not one percent that's not 0.5 that's
not 0.2 I'm talking about point zero one
percent okay and those are people
generally who are like 40 and up and
already married or something like they
do seem a little bougie is that bad I
know that one percent of men she looks
like she's got rich parents her
mannerisms the way she carry herself the
outfit how bushy it looks she looked
like she got rich parents or like less
than one percent of men or something I'd
say
probably 150 to a quarter of a million a
year
it's my guess
okay and you would contribute also 50
50.
okay correct yeah like half what would
it have to be to support this life which
is so funny because I saw this video the
other day where it was saying like
if your wife can spend more than you
make like you need to make more money so
it really just depends
um if your wife spends more than you can
make you need to lady you need to shut
the [ __ ] up and stop especially if it's
not your money
you need to be sensible with your money
like
stop what do you think is the median
income for age 31.
um as of right now I think it's probably
like between mid 50s maybe 60
45
000.
yeah sure wow
you [ __ ] are really poor
the median
um I'm gonna guess like
I don't know is it like 80
48 000 for 32. okay yeah and even at the
time even at the top
35 which was the end of your range yeah
um the median is 52 776 so my
expectations are not realistic so you
said you want 500k but what do you think
the median income is for a 30 year old
60k 70k
50k it is 45
000.
oh my god really yeah poor people ew
yeah you noticing
that's what y'all man how do you live
yeah I I I honestly believe these are
are people coming from Richmond some of
them at least
the way she said 45 she couldn't
conceptualize the idea that some of you
live on that kind of stuff you buy bum
bum cream wait till she finds out that
some of you live on less
this is the median oh you've worked so
hard you precious little thing you look
at you poor person with those boogers oh
you don't have boogers boy oh where are
the Flies that's not a booger that's a
two are we gonna be shooting World
Vision commercials in America
wow yeah I think one time I was
traveling through Uganda and I saw some
of your brethren and sisters there on
the side of the road there yeah so it
was nice how did you make it to America
how do you like rides and stuff it was
not toilets it was not you sitting in a
hole I refused I had them deliver a
hotel as well as a bathroom inside the
hotel to my location in Uganda that was
not Uganda that I was South L.A
there was a lot of black people
[Applause]
I had a lot of cocoa butter and stuff I
was like oh [ __ ] get that at Walmart
stop
bougie yeah
what about the top one percent top one
percent of men at 30.
[Music]
um
well I thought it was 500 000 but yes
okay yeah you know what I I think we
figured out these are rich kids whoa
that's the only way she thought that
people have a 30 are making 500 000. the
median
the median was 500k bruh like let's see
what you're gonna revise it tonight
remember we did a video a while back on
USC students uh who are like how much
does your man they were like yeah yeah
yeah but they just do understand yeah
these women are in their 30s and they
still don't know
said no so for 400 000. 338
yeah so
um let's see I mean 338 is still okay
3538 oh yeah that's fine that's
acceptable
this is crazy
you're asking 127 is closest to the top
10 percent of men so I would say it's
probably top five percent at 31 if I had
to guess so top only the top five
percent of men at 31 are making a
hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars and what you have to keep in
mind is like how many of these dudes are
single how do these dudes live in your
area they're taking a global population
the [ __ ] are actually not gay
like what is your local area like for
that kind of economy yeah a lot of these
dudes you know where they're
concentrated in places like San
Francisco in metropolitan areas where
there's a booming economy for these high
incomes so you may not even have access
to these dudes who are driving up this
percentage upwards these [ __ ]
not even looking at you how many of them
are available and also these guys are
not dating at the same income level so
they're looking everywhere so you're
competing for everybody for a dude score
in a small percentage field and who may
not even be available and also aren't
the most likely to practice monogamy or
Fidelity because they got the most
amount of options understand it's like
you have to look beyond the numbers to
understand what your odds actually are
it's like oh 10 I got great no that's
not what that [ __ ] means that's what
that [ __ ] means
so just think about that I don't know
maybe 80.
it's actually 41 000. you're lying for a
27 year old I just 27 year old I just
like everything is so expensive nowadays
like I guess it yeah that's fine no
worries cut it in half 41 000 that's
shorty will bring it home
Hey listen sometimes sometimes when you
know a white woman Listen to Too Much
ASAP Rocky all of a sudden she thinks
she's part of ASAP Scott ASAP Karen like
yo listen lady ASAP Hey listen lady you
not getting in the squad I don't care
what it is I think I'm understanding
what's happening now I think I get it
but I'm gonna I'm Gonna Save it I know
what it is I know what it is it's the
same thing whenever you ask a girl how
much do you rate oh I'm a 10. they think
that because they think in their head
they attend they can get that one
percent that's it they think that's what
it is there's a correlation right there
everyone thinks of the main character
so everyone thinks they're going to be
the exception nobody thinks they're a
side mission the Ruth is there's a rule
because somebody's gonna fit in that
[ __ ] it's not entirely bad
overestimating yourself is how you lead
yourself to having outstanding results
beyond what is normally expected of you
so I'm not totally mad at having high
ambitions
the problem with these ladies is that
when they describe
their High ambition their High ambition
is being chosen
it's not being proactive you know what
I'm trying to say generally speaking I'm
speaking after
it's not them putting in hundreds of
hours to create a company it's not them
making these startups it's them being
like I may try to look good so I'm gonna
get chosen that's their idea of high
ambition median income never eclipses 65
000 regardless of age
so 70 to 100 is above the median well
somebody's gonna have a sugar mama
hey shout outs to you I appreciate that
she said hey boo I guess I'm bringing
home the bacon she ain't hesitate shout
outs to her for a 32 year old what do
you think the median income is
for this age specifically
for a 42 year old 32 year old 32 year
old the age that you check I think it's
250 000.
it's 52 000. what no it's not
the damn America and then and then
what's the top 25 of a 37 year old
dang maybe it's two hundred thousand
eighty six what no it's not the top
she's just just yeah it's okay play that
[ __ ] play that [ __ ]
oh
Abba's not doing well no the only way I
could ever imagine a black woman saying
stuff like that because she rich rich
she came from Richmond that's the only
way I could see that
what happened maybe Rich parents is not
teaching their kids about money why
would they what a failure on the parents
behalf what a failure on the parents
behalf in terms of educating their
[ __ ] kids if you got all this extra
money that means that you should release
10 is 137 000. the top one percent of
earners at 37 years old top one
percenters right right like we're
talking
one percent three hundred and four
thousand like what is causing women to
want the one percenters I think a lot of
it is like social media hype and just
this Grand idea of what's attainable
nowadays yeah man maybe I'm unaware I
guess maybe I'm unaware the women I date
don't say stuff like this what are the
expectations I guess I've been dating
well before I made any money on YouTube
and I've been dating afterwards and like
I don't hear yeah this kind of rhetoric
but it's not like you don't date those
girls
the wrist rates I've dated women who had
money you've dated but I mean it's not
it's not the the by saying it's not the
most of them right
no I I'd say this
I don't know how pervasive this kind of
Lane going to talk is I've heard the six
figure stuff quite often but the rest of
this no the rest of this is like this
crazy yeah it's crazy all my experience
I've never heard stuff like that so
but they all look like they were bougie
they look like they came from money or
they got some rich parents so they got
rich sugar daddy something they got they
got somebody financing their life that's
what it looks like none of these people
sign like they make mostly money from
their job so and just be listening to
that even well even the girl that said
that she was going to be a sugar mama
for a woman to say well I guess I'm
going to be a sugar mama
you gotta be aware of the money you got
oh that's the median well my chances are
that I'm gonna get that so I'm gonna
make more money because I already packed
so even that it's kind of a proof that
they was making money yeah yeah
but maybe we're unaware maybe we're
missing a piece to this puzzle so that's
where you guys can come in leave your
comments below let us know what we're
missing because this is uh this is kind
of wild to see grown ass women saying
this goofy [ __ ] but maybe maybe the
truth is a lot of people just don't
understand money and there's a huge
singular this population that's not
working for it I wish Courtney would
have asked him how much money they make
or what what what kind of financial
background they have in terms of their
parents that would have cleared up
everything if these were poor middle
class people and America's got a
sickness then we have a problem very big
sickness if these are from Richmond then
I'll let it slide